>> Okay, Michael.
>> Okay, so problem one, where you're maximizing the
number of 1s, to represent the optima here, or the
influence of any given bit on the fitness value,
they're all independent. They all just contribute whatever they contribute.
And so I don't see any reason to capture
other dependencies. We're, we're, you know, local information is enough.
Is that, is that enough to say that the answer,
that the one goes in the last box for independent?
>> That's correct.
>> But it's, I guess, I guess what
I don't quite understand is in, in the case
of the, so we want to know, what's the
probability, yeah, it's a funny thing we're representing, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So if we, the, like, the third position, we're saying,
well what's the probability that if this is a 1 that we're
going to be above a certain value, and what's the probability if,
if it's a zero, we're going to be above a certain value.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that doesn't really exactly capture
the way the fitness function works. But
I guess, oh, I guess because we're drawing from, we're drawing the
rest of the things at random, the rest of the values at random?
>> Mm-hm. Yeah, we are.
>> So is that where the meaning comes from, then?
>> Yeah, think about it this way. Remember, the probability distribution
that we care about, p sub theta, is basically uniform for all
x's such that the fitness value is greater than or equal
to theta. So imagine we start out with theta equal to 0,
let's say, which is the lowest value that you could
get? Well then, what's probability of bit 1 being a 1?
>> Okay
>> For all values greater than or equal to, well, it's 1/2.
>> Okay.
>> Because every single value is okay. And so
in order to get a uniform distribution across n
bits, I can sample each bit independently, uniformly, and
that will give me an overall uniform distribution. Agreed?
>> I do agree with that, yeah.
>> Okay. Now, at the very, very end,
when I have all 1s as the maximum value, that's also easy to represent.
Because the probability, what's the probability of
bit 1 being 1? For the optimum value.
>> 1.
>> Yes, the probability of bit 2 is?
>> And the probability of bit 3?
>> Point, no, 1.
>> Exactly, and they all can be independently represented.
So we can definitely represent the minimum theta value.
>> Streams, yeah.
>> Yeah, so, we can represent the maximum.
The question here is, or at least in terms of, you know, you're
likely to find the answer. The question here is, can this distribution represent
values of theta in between? So imagine theta was, let's say I had
four bits here, like we're doing here. And let's imagine theta was 2.
>> Good.
>> Now, notice that when theta is 2, it's not just the number of
points that will give you exactly 2, it's the ones that will give you
at least 2. 2.
>> Right. And 3, and 4. So how many
different ways are there to get 4? Well, there's only
one way to get a value of 4, and that
is all 1s. How many different ways can you do
3? Well, there's 4 ways to get 3. You
basically have to choose the one that you give as
0, right? And each one of those bits, each one
of these values will be a 1, three quarters of
the time. And how many different ways can you
get 2? Well it's n choose 2, which is, something.
>> 6.
>> 6, so you can actually write all of those out and count
the number of times that each one is a 1. And those are all
your samples, and you just simply estimate it. And you'll end up with a
uniform distribution which will be consistent with
the examples that I just sampled from,
but will probably not exactly capture p sub theta. because it will sometimes be
able to generate with probability greater than 0, say, a value of all 0s.
>> Yes, okay, good. That was what I was concerned about. And
so this is, this is just an approximation, even in the simple case.
>> Right. And so, and that's actually
pretty interesting, right? So, yeah, we know that
the extreme values can be represented by
an independent distribution, but it's not clear that
all the values in between can be represented by
such a simple distribution. But that's always going to be
the case. What you want is a distribution that
will definitely capture the optimum and, or optima, and gives
you a good chance of generating samples that get
you closer to the optimum along the way. So even
though in the case before where theta is 2,
we might still generate examples where you get a fitness
of 0 or 1, you have a high probability if you generate enough
samples of actually getting values of theta greater than 2, 3, or 4, even.
>> Got it.
>> Okay.
>> Alright, so I, so, given that, I think I can do the next
two without too much more difficulty. So,
for number 2 problem 2, maximize the number
of alternations, we pointed out that it's really important to, to know who your,
what your neighbor is, because you want
to be a different value than your neighbor.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the chain gives you exactly that information without anything extra.
>> Right.
>> So I would put the 2 in the first box.
>> Yep.
>> And finally, well, there's only one box left. So I'd put the 3
in the middle box. But I guess the interesting to, to look at here
is that it is surprisingly appropriate, right?
So, that the coloring problem, it is
specifically saying, well, the, my value depends
on, you know, what's a good value
for me depends on, I guess, several of my neighbors, not just one.
>> Right.
>> But I feel I could, you could capture a
lot of the necessary information by finding a good dependency tree.
>> Right. And it turns out that in practice, as our readers
and listeners will see, from one of the resources that we're making
available to them, that in practice, mimic does very well on problems
like this. Even where you have really complicated graph structures. It tends
to do much better than a lot of the other
randomized optimization problems. And that's because what we've got here
in this graph is structure. And what mimic is trying
to represent, is in fact, structure. In fact, in all
of these cases, well, except for the, the first case.
There's not a single answer often. There are possibly many
answers, but the answers all have in common their relationship
to one, to some underlying structure. So in the maximizing
alternations case, you have 010101 or 101010. These are
two completely different values. In fact, as you pointed out
when I asked you this earlier, they're complimentary. But,
each one has a very simple structure, which is, every
bit is different from its neighbor to the l,
actually both of its neighbors. Every bit is different from
its neighbors. And that doesn't matter what their values are.
Given the value of one of them, it actually completely
determines the value of everything else. And so mimic doesn't
get lost trying to bounce back and forth between this
possible maximum and this possible maximum. Instead, it represents both
of them at the same time. Because the only thing
that matters is the relationships. So, in fact, that gets
us to the last bit of things I wanted to
talk about, which are sort of practical features of mimic
and what we kind of learn by thinking this way.